what was the insight around physical
attractiveness and happiness yeah so
they've done studies of like 11 000
couples what predicts romantic happiness
there's just a total disconnect between
what people are swiping for or trying to
date and what actually makes people
happy the things that do have at least
some predictive power whether i'm happy
with someone else are like these
psychological variables secure
attachment style growth mindset
conscientiousness satisfaction with life
and the things that have basically no
predictive power are a lot of
superficial things conventional
attractiveness the height of your
partner the particular occupation of
your partner so all of the things that
online apps optimize for on the front
end yeah will people change based on
knowing that i don't know i think it may
be coded in our dna that we're drawn to
beauty and height and status but if you
can i really do recommend overruling
some of those instincts because they're
really not a path to long-term happiness